we all are aware of what the hype house
is okay yeah how the funny ahead of you
have a high power related thing too I
have a joke about that yeah okay go
ahead hype house we all know what it is
right we sound like some shitty morning
show the hype house if you're not aware
of it you should be it's what your kids
are watching 19 teenagers in one house
and they're kissing each other on camera
on the lips so I like I you know we're
discussing me like didn't know whether
or not kids live there yeah I've did a
little bit more research and like half
the kids live there and it's kind of
funny they did like they open this video
YouTube videos not to like most of them
yeah and there's a high post YouTube
channel this is now what I don't go to
this yet but okay actually yeah just
search hype house alright go to their
YouTube channel uh hype the hype house
right there yeah there so oh they [ __ ]
delete it okay there oh no - welcome to
the hype house yeah yeah and then like
you seeing this [ __ ] click pause and
then go view more show more on the
description okay okay so here's what we
just so there's these are the members so
it says official members yeah in the
video the kick goes like yeah gives like
10 of us that live here the other ones
like live with their parents back in
wherever [ __ ] Ohio whatever yeah and
they travel in and they film videos here
blah blah blah right it's a bunch of
tik-tok kids that all film tic TOCs in
this one house and I just think it's
first of all I think it's funny they
call them members right like it's a
[ __ ] Soho House for [ __ ] Jen's II
yeah yeah yeah so anyways so tic toc is
their main [ __ ] right uh-huh
so this one kid Alex Warren the top kid
there yeah search his name on youtube
and watch his newest video and tell me
if it if he reminds you of anyone that
one girlfriend wakes up in pool prank oh
yeah first of all and this the yeah it's
just the dobrik mother but yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean the thumbnail already
the thumbnail on the title already go
skip how do we know how many volume
decided to prepare it
Wow yeah I mean voila Spanish whatever
you wait wait just play to the intro
okay it's just grilled cheese oh oh hey
this is your first time seeing this kid
yeah really yeah what let's the first
time where have you seen him I've gone
down this hole already you later ah I
[ __ ] why didn't you say anything to
me it's a mind boggling it's freaking me
the [ __ ] out don't you knew I didn't
know about this kid I mean I so I like I
like searched his name or whatever and I
see that there are some like breakdowns
of like comparing his videos to David
everybody knows right yeah but it's like
God way [ __ ] worse oh yeah yeah I
mean yeah and no one said anything since
then uh what else can you say I mean
it's so so transparent what he's doing
no but doubts down to the [ __ ] laughs
Newton he copied his voice I don't
understand yeah that put that part scary
just freaking me out
yeah it's weird as [ __ ] yeah it's oh man
well first of all let me say sorry no no
go ahead look my main my main point my
main point is this this is why it freaks
me out so much okay you know you know
david dobrik okay let's go cuz I'm sure
there's one person listening was I have
no idea who we're just like sitting here
like I thought so this is this is kid
Alex Warren it's part of the hype house
if you don't know the [ __ ] that is
basically some kiddies to be in team ten
and some parents got together and they
bought a mansion and they thought it'd
be a good idea to put a bunch of
pre-pubescent tick stalkers in there you
know namely big stars big stars like
Charlie D'Amelio you know yeah Prada
endorsed creator yeah and it's not even
but it's like not all prepubescent it's
like 15 year olds but then some of them
are like 24
oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] we our boy Lord
Farquaad anyway so there's this do
named Alex Warren and buddy has carbon
copy david dobrik like yes the so he
boasts he boasts vlogs yeah they're all
a little bit over four minutes yeah they
all are the same format where they start
with like a little sketch making cuts to
the intro which is just text it's quick
and then it cuts back and it's all like
pranks and sketches that he doesn't with
his friends right now you can say okay
he didn't invent [ __ ] vlogs like this
you know the intro format words doesn't
sketch and then it cuts to an intro
that's been done for a long time I used
to do that but mostly because David
overdid it but like I also like David
Ober didn't invent that right now cold
opens is not but this is a whole nother
level where he's he's basically cloning
David Albert's like personality and his
mannerisms at the same time yeah yeah
you and the the most identifying thing
to me is that you know david dobrik the
most unique thing i think about him is
he's a laugh talker yo I've never seen
anyone else do this besides david dobrik
mmm-hmm when he when he talks to the
camera he talks like this yeah and you
know not no shade no shade on the dude
at all
yeah I really I think I respect what
I've done for the platform and
everything but he's a laugh talker yeah
he is I've never seen anyone else do
that before it's very unique to him yeah
this kid laughs talks I mean I think is
more than that - it's like the cadence
like even in this first 30 seconds you
know a lot of Gordon likes just like
that in and of its almost like he looked
in the mirror realized he had the same
vocal tone I was like I'm going for it
yeah man yeah then laugh the laugh is
freaking me out
meanwhile I just grilled cheese it's
just grilled cheese okay
yeah like Sogo drainie is learning like
doing this when he laughs that's where
he talks with scam right right this
really original idea of putting culver
in the pool while she's sleeping that
was not a good deep sleeper hey yeah
yeah yeah deep sleeper yes I don't know
man if you can go down the hole if you
care you can go down that hole if you
care you can slide down that hole if you
care I've never seen some [ __ ] like this
ever
yeah it's um it's weird it's like a very
clear like I want to be famous thing um
the whole I mean the whole hype house
thing is super contrived I've said that
before here's the thing that I don't
think I said before it like this hit me
randomly before we left for Australia
I'm like yo the hive house is just the
American version of a Chinese gaming
house like yeah
the American World of Warcraft was
popular yeah all these Chinese gaming
houses they take 16 teenagers and lock
them in a in a room in a house and be
like you have to farm gold
oh yeah only two hours a day yeah you
know that's all the [ __ ] these kids are
it's just like a very like first world
version of that they all lock these kids
in a house and they're like all right
make content yeah and all this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] brainless and cheap
it's like it feels like a borderline
feels like a bot is creating it yeah
they're just spitting this [ __ ] out yeah
they get like you know all these [ __ ]
these dudes and these girls that are
generically relatable to a lot of people
and they guy just got them [ __ ] doing
the whoa and renegade for 12 hours a day
yeah it's just like you know there's
just cracking the whip one one thing
that I didn't really understand that I
understand now though is that like like
Charlie D'Amelio and the other chick and
like they're making up choreography like
a lot of the times these dances that go
viral they they're the ones that like
make them up and really yeah
them yeah and so they're actually like
are you sure yeah I yeah I'm like 80%
sure I mean I'm sure they copy other
people's dances for sure but they've
definitely made some up ya know their
dancers like that's what they do and so
there is a little bit of like artistic
integrity to some of the stuff that they
do but then there's [ __ ] like this which
is like a direct [ __ ] clone yeah of
someone else's [ __ ] I don't know I was
not under the impression that Charlie
made up any of her own dances yeah that
I did not I did not know that it was in
the beginning early the Milly oh sure
she's just repurposing pieces of other
dances I mean she might be making up her
own [ __ ] now but in the beginning of I
was under the impression this is just a
kid dancing other people's dances who's
the other chick the blond one I can find
no I thought they were like made up [ __ ]
I don't think they do man I think they
do I'm pretty sure they don't I'm like
I'm I'm like 60% positive that all right
well whoever is in the no comment let us
know about that yeah it's a pressing
issue because someone's got to make the
dance move someone's got to make the
routines up it's usually just like other
random people with like small numbers
and then they just like a lot of these
[ __ ] that's like the does like the
big beef with like renegade it was like
that young girl made up the dance and
then all these kids like just uploaded
their own sounds doing the dance and
then the girl the little girls never got
acknowledged for it and like that just
is like a super common thing I guess I'm
tick-tock and that's like a gripe people
have a tick-tock is that this hype house
[ __ ] is like they just like see [ __ ]
that's like smaller they go oh it's ours
now yeah you know they just completely
erase the person who made it yeah and
then they get you know by virtue but by
way of being in the hype house and
having like a big following it's just
like they just keep sort of like
snowballing oh yeah it's also true in
just everything
yeah yeah yeah remember how you said
happen on vine all the time someone
create a trend yeah and like out all the
big people would just do it
oh yeah and not tag the person yeah I
got tagged with what the who wants to be
a millionaire bit oh yeah all those
[ __ ] tagged my yeah yeah yeah
but it was like super what I always
thought was funny about that was like
you're still like copying something you
know what I'm saying like there were
trends where it was sort of like people
would like elevate the joke or like tag
the joke and it's like oh that's funny
but the bigger creators so to speak
would just literally do the other
person's bit just like a beat for bean
it was like well you didn't really come
up with that yeah like you couldn't you
couldn't like watch a stand-up comedian
then go this bit is inspired by Nate
bargatze and you just do the same
[ __ ] bit you can't do that you know
that's like that's what they were doing
like it doesn't make it oh my god dude
how easy was Santa beef yes do that yeah
in this wire I'll be like no no just
like this is a bit that one of my
favorite comedians does yeah and then
just do it yeah that's why I like
tick-tock and in vine and all I did is
like this weird pretend place where like
people like get to play along that they
like have talent I feel like it ya know
it's like he didn't really come up with
damn near anything you're doing okay
great
you